NOTORIOUSLY UNPLEASANT
AIRLINE PASSENGER IN THE
PROCESS WHO WOULD YOU SIDE
WITH?
THE 2018 WINTER OLYMPICS IN
SOUTH KOREA, JUST ABOUT A
MONTH AWAY.
AND IF ANY TRANSGENDER
ATHLETE SEEK TO COMPETE THEY
WILL BE WELCOMED WITH OPEN
ARMS.
IOC RULES ALLOW FOR
TRANSGENDER ATHLETES TO
COMPETE AS THEIR PREFERRED
GENDER.
BIOLOGICAL MALE WINNING A
GOLD MEDAL IN A WOMEN'S
EVENT NOW SEEMS A MATTER OF
JOANNA HARPER IS
TRANSGENDERED AN AN ATHLETE.
AND ARGUES THAT TRANSGENDER
COMPETITORS DON'T ENJOY ANY
JOANNA, THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO IN THIS AGE OF
GENDER FLUIDITY TAKE A
RELAXED VIEW OF IT AND
ACCEPT THAT YOU CHOOSE WHICH
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO SPORT,
WHEN IT COMES TO WHO IS THE
RUNNING AROUND A 400-METER
BIOLOGICAL SEXES.
HAVE MALE HAVE DISTINCT
ADVANTAGE.
WHERE ARE THEY GOING WRONG
ON THAT?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL,
AND SO TO SUGGEST THAT
BIOLOGY IS DIMORPHIC IS
INCORRECT.
IT IS LEARN I TRUE THAT
PEOPLE GONE THROUGH MALE
PURSUANT, ESPECIALLY DO HAVE
SUBSTANTIAL ADVANTAGES.
WOMEN CAN ONLY COMPETE IN
WOMEN SPORTS AFTER THEY HAVE
THERAPY.
CHARACTERISTICS AND
ESPECIALLY THOSE
AND THE SECOND THING I WOULD
LIKE TO SAY IS THAT I HAVE
ALWAYS ADMITTED THAT
TRANSGENDER WOMEN HAVE
ADVANTAGES OVER TYPICAL
WOMEN.
BUT ALSO DISADVANTAGES, TOO.
THE IMPORTANT QUESTION IS
CAN THE TWO GROUPS COMPETE
AGAINST ONE ANOTHER.
TESTS AND THE TESTING THAT
YOU MENTIONED.
WHERE THEY SAY YOU HAVE
TO -- MAYBE CAN YOU ACTUALLY
EXPLAIN THIS IN LAYMAN'S
TERMS.
YOU ARE A SCIENTIST.
YOU UNDERSTAND A LOT OF
THIS.
HAVE YOUR TESTOSTERONE
LEVELS BO BELOW 10 NANO
MODEL.
IF I CAN THINK ABOUT I CAN
THINK ABOUT WHAT A NANOMOLS
PER LITER.
90% OF FEMALE ATHLETES THEIR
TESTOSTERONE LEVELS ARE
AROUND 3 PER LITER.
IN OTHER WORDS, THIS YOU
WERE LIMIT IS THREE TIMES
SO IT SEEMS LIKE A KIND OF
SITUATION.
RECOMMENDED THAT WE LOWER
THAT LIMIT FROM 10 TO 5.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT'S A
LIMIT.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF
TRANSGENDER WOMEN WILL KEEP
THEIR TESTOSTERONE BELOW 3
AND IN FACT BELOW 2 AND
USUALLY BELOW ONE.
>> Mark: RIGHT.
>> THIS IS YOU WERE LIMIT.
I ABSOLUTELY AGREE 10 IS TOO
HIGH AND OUR COMMITTEE HAS
RECOMMENDED BRINGING IT DOWN
TO FIVE.
>> Mark: YOU MENTION THAT
IT'S NOT LIKE A BINARY
BOY/GIRL THING.
THERE WAS -- I THINK SHE WAS
SOUTH AFRICAN FLEET WHO
COUPLE YEARS BACK AND HER
FELLOW FEMALE COMPETITORS
WERE CONVINCED THAT AT A
CERTAIN LEVEL SHE WAS
TRANSGENDER.
AND THE AUTHORITIES ENDED UP
TRANSGENDERED BECAUSE HER
LEVELS WERE BELIEVED TO BE
EXTRAORDINARILY HIGH.
OF MY CROW REGULATION OF THE MIO
OF MY CROW REGULATION OF THE MIE
OF MY CROW REGULATION OF THE MIU
OF MY CROW REGULATION OF THE MIA
OF MY CROW REGULATION OF THE MII
OF MY CROW REGULATION OF THE MIN
OF MY CROW REGULATION OF THE MIO
OF MY CROW REGULATION OF THE MI
OF MY CROW REGULATION OF THE MIH
OF MY CROW REGULATION OF THE MIE
D.N.A. OF EACH PARTICIPANT?
>> FIRST OF ALL, THE ATHLETE
IN QUESTION WAS ALMOST
BUT HERMAPHRODITE MAY BE A
TERM.
INTERSECTION PIMA HAVE A MIX
OF MALE AND FEMALE
CHARACTERISTICS.
AND SHE IS ALMOST
UNDOUBTEDLY INTERSECTION.
THERE ARE DIFFERENT ISSUES
THAN WITH TRANSGENDER
ATHLETES.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO SEPARATE
THE TWO.
BUT, AGAIN, IT IS IMPORTANT
TO HAVE FAIR PLAY.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO -- THAT
INTRODUCING INTERSECTION
AND/OR TRANSGENDER ATHLETES
DOES NOT OVERLY EFFECT THE
PLAYING FIELD THAT EXISTS.
REPRESENTED IN WOMEN'S
SPORTS.
IN OTHER WORDS, IF YOU WERE
TO LOOK AT THE POPULATION OF
TRANSGENDER ATHLETES, YOU
WOULD EXPECT THAT THERE
WOULD BE A LOT MORE ATHLETES
THAN THERE ACTUALLY ARE.
>> Mark: WE WILL SEE WHERE
WOMEN JUST END UP RUNNING